INSTRUCTOR: Welcome visitors
to this adventure guide,
where you will learn how to
leverage your data by sorts,
filters, and sets, oh my!
Often students get
intimidated by some
of the powerful
tools in Tableau,
and I can think of another
group of individuals
who made themselves afraid just
simply by saying the words.
Well, watch this short clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Lions and tigers and bears!
Oh, my!
Lions and tigers and bears!
[END PLAYBACK]
INSTRUCTOR: All right.
Here in this clip, you see the
Tin Man, Dorothy, and scarecrow
as they head down
the yellow brick
road, getting themselves all
worked up about lions and tigers
and bears, and they
were interrupted
by the roar of a
lion, which they later
found out wasn't very brave, but
helped them get to the Emerald
City and to the wizard.
I'm hoping that this
adventure guide will
help you feel empowered to use
some of these tools in Tableau
to create and see
insights for your data.
So we're going to
take a look at sorts--
the data, the alphabetic
field, manual and nested.
We're going to learn
about filters--
the selection, wildcard,
condition, and top filters.
We're going to touch just
a little bit on parameters
in this adventure guide.
And then we'll round it
off with groups and sets.
So let's dive first into
your adventure guide
entitled advanced, sort,
filter, and set start.
And you should find yourself
on the Overview tab.
And so whenever you work in
business, order does matter.
And Tableau gives you this power
to sort, filter, create groups,
and create parameters, which
gives you a lot of flexibility
with your data.
So let's go ahead and look at
this particular simple summary
table.
One of the features that
you're familiar with
is the ascending and descending
way to sort on the toolbar.
So if you want to see the
smallest values on top
and largest on bottom, then you
would click the ascending sort.
If you want to see the
highest to lowest values,
you would need to select
the descending sort.
If you want more
control of your sorting,
then you need to open
up the sorting dialog
box for a particular field.
So in this case, you can see
I've got customer stayed on rows
and there's been a
sort applied to that.
I can see that because I've
got this icon right here.
And if I do the dropdown arrow,
I can actually clear that sort.
So now that icon is gone.
But we want to have more
options for our sort.
So I'll click the sort field
here, drag my dialog box off
to the left here.
And then you can see that
there are a variety of ways
that you can sort by.
So you can by your data,
alphabetic, field, manual,
and nested.
Let's just go through these.
So to sort by your
data, now our data
that we have showing in
this field is string data.
So to sort string data,
you alphabetize it.
So this particular
sort is the same
as the second sort,
which is the alphabetic.
However, if you were
to use a numeric field,
then it would sort
by those numbers
instead of the alphabetized.
So then you also have the
ability to sort by field.
And this is what this ascending
and descending quick commands
or tools on the
toolbar do, that they
do ascending and descending.
But in this dialog box, you
could change the field's name.
Right now, we have order total.
And you can also
change the aggregation.
So let's just say
I'll go to average.
Now notice in a sort,
it does it on the fly.
I don't click apply.
Nothing else.
It just does it when I select
it within the dialog box.
And so that's something that's
different than a filter.
And we'll talk about that
and show that in a minute.
But let's go back to sum here.
And now I can see that
I've got from an ascending
versus descending.
And that's what we saw
here when we did this
with the ascending
and descending.
Now you also have the
option to do manual.
So say, for instance, I'm
going to be presenting
some data to some
representatives
from the great state of Ohio.
So I want to put
that at the very top.
So I'll click that to be on top.
And then I am going to
fly and go to Tennessee.
And I want to have that
at the top as well.
But I want it below Ohio.
So you can see you can just
order, manually order or sort
your data, which
can be very helpful.
And then finally,
you have nested.
And we'll talk about
that in just a moment.
First of all, I want to
show you in the dialog box
how you can also click
the Clear button.
So by doing so removes
that icon in the pill
and knows that there's
no sort being applied.
So just to let you know, you
cannot sort by a dimension text
length.
You can only do data, the
alphabetic, the field, manual,
and nested.
So let's dive into
a nested sort here.
And a nested sort is also
on this-- you'll find this
on the tab entitled sort.
And when you have a single
level of organization,
like we just were looking
at that simple table,
it's fairly
straightforward to sort.
However, when you have multiple
levels of organization,
then you need a special kind
of sort, and that nested sort.
So this sheet has two different
levels of organization.
On the rows shelf, you've
got product category
with the bath,
gift, and olive oil.
And then you also
have the sales region.
And right now, these are
organized by alphabetical order.
But let's say that I want to
leave the product categories
in their current
alphabetical order,
but I want to sort the sales
regions within each of them
based on their sales total.
So right now, they're
not sorted in that way.
So to do that, I need
to create a nested sort.
And in this case, the word
nested refers to a bird's nest.
You have eggs in
the nest and then
the bird sits on
top of the eggs.
And then within the nest, you
have these multiple layers,
if you will.
So I want to sort
based on sales region.
So I'm going to go to
the sales region pill
and I'm going to do the
dropdown and select sort.
Here I have all of those
sorts I just discussed.
And I'm going to
select now nested.
So here you can see that Tableau
is quickly determined the best
type of sort that it believes
I want to do, and it's correct.
I've got the field
name on order total
and I have the
aggregation to be sum.
Now I'm not going
to do ascending.
I'm actually going to
change it to descending.
So I want you to notice which
regions in your own view
are the highest and the lowest.
And so here can see
that the South Central
East is the highest in every
region in terms of its product
category.
And then the North Central
West is the lowest.
So one thing you might
recommend to maybe director
is to see if the North Central
West representatives could
shadow the South Central East
to perhaps help them improve
their sales and their outcomes.
So that is a nested sort.
The next item we're
going to talk about
is the power of a
filter and how filters
are different than sorts.
So when you save data
in the Tableau workbook,
the program maintains
an internal list
of all the values in the column.
And so if you want
to filter a column so
that only certain
values appear, you
can take advantage
of that internal list
by creating a filter.
So let's go ahead and click on
the Filter tab on the bottom
there.
And you'll see I have a
very similar simple table.
And what I want to do is I
want to see sales results only
for a few of these
sales regions.
And so I can drag the sales
region onto the filter shelf
and then I'll see this
dialog box that opens up.
And you can see
there's options here.
We have general,
we have wildcard,
We have condition, and top.
And we'll go through
all of those.
But let's just check
out the general first.
You can see I've got
everything selected right now.
I could click none and then
I can click all back again.
I could deselect a
few of these regions.
Here are the northeast and
northwest and click Apply.
And then you can see what
happens within the table itself.
I recommend as a best practice
when you're learning Tableau
is to just keep the
filter's dialog box open
and then just click Apply
to see what's happening.
I can also use the exclude here.
And when I hit
Apply, you'll notice
that I have these
sales regions that are
checked with a strikethrough.
And so I know that only
the northeast and northwest
are showing because
the rest are excluded.
So when I deselect that, that
strikethrough is now removed
and I hit Apply.
And now you can see that
I've got everything,
except for the
northeast and northwest.
So I'm going to go ahead and
just select them all and apply
and we'll move down to
the next filter which
is the wildcard filter.
So wildcard lets you
limit the data to values
that follow a specific pattern.
So if we look at our
data, the product category
doesn't really have
a specific pattern.
We only have three of those.
But there is some patterns
in the sales region.
And that's what I'm
going to look at.
So let's go ahead and
click on the wildcard here.
And you can see that
there are a few options.
You have contains, start with,
ends with, and exactly matches.
So let's start off with this
contains and just go ahead
and type in the word North.
And then again,
we'll just hit Apply.
And you'll see that it is
showing these regions that
have the word north.
Now you may have
noticed in my data
that I'm missing some
regions that are in the north
because I did not spell
out the whole name.
So I'm going to just
clear that for a moment.
So we can go back to our data.
And you can see that I have
some with just the capital N.
So I could do starts
with and I could just
have an N. Notice it's not
uppercase or lowercase.
And I can apply that.
And now I've included that.
Now as a rule of thumb, I
don't recommend doing filters
on single letters.
But in this case, the
data set is fairly small.
So it does capture those
regions with just the letter N.
You could also do ends with and
you could type in a word there.
Let's hit Apply.
And just having east there.
And then exactly matches
you have to type in the word
that you're looking for.
This can be very helpful if
you just have a sea of data
and you just need to find a
specific category or product
or sales amount.
So that's the wildcard.
And you can see
it's a powerful tool
to find what you need
to sort your data when
you have those patterns.
So I'm going to go ahead,
before we do this condition 1,
I'm going to click OK here.
And then I'm going to remove
product category from the row.
I'm going to reshuffle
this a little bit.
I'm going to remove sum here and
I'm going to remove this filter.
So I'm just keeping that sales
category or sales region on row.
And I'm going to add in this
sheet count onto my text here.
So what does this is something
that Tableau does automatically.
It counts the amount
of sales that occurred
in each of the regions.
So it's an additional measure
that Tableau has created.
But we're going to use this
for that condition filter.
So say I want to
determine whether or not
or how many sales regions
have fewer than 500 sales.
So I want to go into here,
go into sales region,
go into condition now.
And you can see I want
to select by field.
So I'm going to use that
sheet 1 that I've selected.
Count is correct.
And now I need to select
less than or equal to.
And then I'm going to put 500.
Now before I do this, I want
you to do it on your own.
And then tell me
how many regions
have fewer than 500 sales.
All right, I'm
going to click OK.
And you can see that
there are indeed
only three-- the north
central west, northwest,
and the south central west.
Now I'm going to go back
and edit that filter.
And I could change
that to be 700.
I might want to
include more in there.
So now I can see that I've
got seven-- actually six,
excuse me, regions that
have sales less than 700.
So that is the condition
filter, if you will.
So then the final one
is the top filter.
And that is a way to see
values at the very top.
Now this is a very
small dataset.
But we'll just show how
this works for there.
I'm going to go
ahead and hit Cancel,
I'm going to reorganize this.
I'm going to remove sales
regions from the filter
and I'm going to also
remove sales region
from the row and the count.
So we're just going to
clear our sheet off here.
And I'm going to add
customer state to my row
and I'm going to do
order total onto.
So back to my simple
summary table here.
So say like I want to
display five states that
provided the most value, then
I can create that top filter.
So I'm going to drag customer
state to the filters here.
Go to the top.
And now I can see that I can
actually again select by field.
And I have top.
Tableau automatically puts
10, but I can put down 5 here.
And it does it by order
total, which I have
already as my field and sum.
So you can apply that and then
simply see how many those are.
So I could change
this to be 7, 20.
And this could help in my view.
Maybe I want to create some kind
of a chart or visualization that
will be added to
a dashboard that
has only this amount
of the data showing.
So that's how you use the
filters within Tableau.
Next one we're going to do is to
add a parameter to the filter.
Now this is where we begin
to see some power of Tableau.
And we'll go ahead to
our Tableau worksheet
here and click on the
filter and the parameter.
And you can see
what I have here.
I have a tree map.
And the thing to remember about
parameters in terms of filters
is they act sometimes
very similarly.
But a filter has to use the
data that is within the source.
Parameters are powerful
tools because they're not
dependent on what's
inside the data.
You can go outside of that.
Parameters will be
used more extensively.
And the advanced
data 5400 course.
You might even decide
to use some parameters
for your project,
which would be awesome.
But I want you to remember
that a parameter is not exactly
the same as a filter.
A filter is tied to
the data and can only
reflect what's in the data.
A parameter can take
anything you'd like and do
whatever you'd like.
And we're going to try and
do a little bit of that
here within this
very short demo.
So we're looking
at this tree map.
And you can see that
it is organized,
of course, by the quantities.
We have the extra virgin
olive oil-- bold 12
pack being the
most sold and then
the chili extra virgin olive
oil, et cetera, et cetera.
You can see how that lays out.
So what I'm going to do
is create a top filter.
We just did that.
And I'm going to
add a parameter so I
have control over how many I
want to see within a dialog box.
So I'm going to, first
of all, go into--
and I'm going to do
that based on quantity.
I'm going to create the
parameter based on quantity.
So I'm going to go into
measure names under quantity
and do the down arrow.
Let's see.
And then I'm going
to hit Create.
And you can see I can create a
calculated field, group, bins.
But I'm going to
create a parameter.
And I can rename that.
Let's just do-- you can
rename that whatever you want.
Now integer is correct
for this because the way
that this data is created is,
although I have 12 olive oil
bottles, they're
all in one pack.
So I can't order 1
and 1/2 of those.
I have to order a whole.
So integer is the right one.
But you can see there's
others, there's strings,
there's Boolean,
date, date, and time.
And then there's also float.
So if I were going to have just
numerical values of a variety,
I would just hit float.
But for this case,
I'll have integers.
The current value is 1.
This is all great.
Now allowable values.
This is what I'm going
to see in my view.
I can have all of them,
I can have the list,
or I can have a range.
And this is where you
can do some exploration.
But I'm going to have
a range in this case.
Now the range of values,
the minimum and maximum
actually show exactly what's
in the data right now.
So it's using the
data to recommend
that the minimum would be 1
and the maximum would be 14.
However, again,
this is a parameter.
I can do whatever I want.
So I could have this be 100.
Now that would be a lot
of blank screen there.
So instead I'm going to
move this just to 15, just
so I could see the full range.
And so it's important
to know that there is
flexibility in the parameter.
It's not tied to your data.
So let's just say that you
have a dataset with six values,
but you want to show more.
So what parameter do you
need to change in order
to display the
additional values?
Hopefully, you
selected that, yes,
you need to increase the
maximum range of values
to be one higher.
So that's what we did
here in this example.
So let's go ahead and click OK.
And now you can see
in the parameters,
we have now a new section
here in the sidebar.
And we're going to drag the
product name to the filters card
here.
We're going to go
to our top filter.
We're going to do by field.
And we're going to
maintain top here.
But instead of
putting in a number,
we're going to just
select a parameter.
And it's the parameter
that we just created.
So it's quantity parameter.
We want it still by quantity
and sum, cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
And we're going to hit OK.
So now what's happened?
It's gone to a full
just singular box here.
That's because it's showing
my very top single parameter.
And I need to be
able to show that.
So in order to
show that, I'm just
going to go to my
parameters box.
I'm going to click that
and say show parameter.
And now what I have is I have
the ability to move that.
So see now I can say within my
presentation or my dashboard,
how many parameters affect that.
And those can affect other
charts within a dashboard.
And we'll talk about that later.
But this is how you
create a parameter.
Now let's see.
The last two sections
I'm going to talk about
are groups and sets.
So let's go first to groups
and go to our group tab here.
And when you collect business
data, the more detail,
the better.
But there might be times when
you want to combine two elements
or more into one.
And so here we have this
simple table visualization
that summarizes total
sales by region.
However, if we look at the
north central east and north
central west, you'll see
that this particular region
has a lot fewer sales
than the east does.
And so I'd like to combine
those into a single group.
So I'll do that by selecting it.
And I'll hold down the
Control or Shift key,
depending on if you are a Mac
or PC to select both of those.
And when you do that,
then a dialog box comes up
and you can see that, if
you use the paper clip,
it will show you group members.
And I can hit the
paper clip and it
will combine those two together
and also create a group here
in the dimensions pane.
So note how many sales, both
the north central east and north
central west region had in
terms of combined sales.
So if I want to compare this
group to the rest of the sales
regions, then I can click
this down arrow right here
and I could click include other.
By doing that, I will
group the other categories,
the other sales regions
and compare that
to that sales region.
So to deselect that, you just
go back and unselect that
and then you're back
to where you're at.
The last item of this
adventure guide are sets.
So let's go to our sets.
Tab here on our worksheet.
And sets are
different than groups.
Sets are a combination of items.
So again, kind of similar
to groups, but they
have a different power.
And you'll see
that they actually
act a little bit differently,
especially when you're
trying to do order totals
or to apply them as filters.
So let's go ahead and make the
north central east and north
central west into a set.
So instead of doing
the paper clip,
we'll do this Venn
diagram circle here
and we'll say create set.
Now here I can control
what I want my set.
I can remove items here or I
can exclude them, et cetera.
I can add to the filter
shelf right away.
But we'll do that separately.
I'll just say OK.
Now notice what's
different here.
When you did it for groups, it
combined them within the view.
When you did it for sets, it
actually just created a set
here on the data pane.
So different sort of
attributes that are happening
between groups and sets.
So let's go ahead and
actually make a second set.
I'm going to do
this one right here.
And I'm going to create
this as a set too.
So I'm actually going to
call this the south region.
OK.
And then I'm going to
rename this one too.
I'm going to call
this the north region.
All right.
So here I have my
data and now I'm
going to begin to add
them to my rows shelf.
And I'm going to use
them as a dimension.
So I'm going to go ahead and I'm
going to take my north region
and I'm just going to
place that right here.
So now I've divided
out my data, my regions
by my north region here, which
I've got those two combined.
And then I have myself.
Now the great thing about sets
is then I can apply some totals.
So if I go into
the analysis menu
and then scroll down to totals,
you can see I can show grand,
show row grand totals,
column, et cetera, et cetera.
I'm going to add
all subtotals here.
And now I can see subtotal
for the north region
and then I can also see
it for everything else.
Now for my south region, I can
just add that into the view.
And now I've added that
parsed it out and the out.
And then I can also drag
and drop and remove that.
So there's lots of
flexibility when
it comes to filters and
also groups and sets
and all sorts of tools, oh my!
And hopefully this has given
you confidence to apply them
in your own visualizations.